seit über 1000 jahren haben philosophie
und wissenschaften der islamischen welt
in europa wichtige spuren hinterlassen
der philosoph dominik perlen und der
islamwissenschaftler und rudolf sprechen
mit mir über die islamische philosophie
und die mobilität des denkens zwischen
orient und okzident herzlich willkommen
herr rudolph wenn man an die islamische
welt denkt dann denkt man heutzutage
wenig an rationalität und philosophie ja
zu unrecht im übrigen auch heute gibt es
rationalität
aber man denkt vor allen dingen an die
lange tradition von rationalität und von
philosophie die ganz beachtliche und die
immer auch im kontakt mit anderen
kulturregionen gewesen ist wann beginnt
diese islamische philosophie
die beginnt schon sehr früh um 8 19
jahrhundert wichtig für den westen wird
sie dann im dreizehnten jahrhundert denn
zu dieser zeit wurden viele arabische
texte ins lateinische übersetzt und
intensiv gelesen aber der stadt sagen
wir mal so um 900 herum was ist
eigentlich die initialzündung für die
islamische welt des denkens die
initialzündung ist zum einen der kontakt
mit der griechischen philosophie und die
übersetzung wichtiger kritische texte
ins arabische
und zum anderen natürlich auch die
entwicklung einer theologie die
denkanstöße gegeben hat die dann in der
philosophie aufgegriffen worden sind und
die grundpfeiler also sind von anfang an
religion nicht nur das islamische raich
hat eine breite gesellschaft neue
hervorgebracht die mit großem interesse
und mit großem wissensbedarf agiert da
gibt es praktische interessen erst
einmal
dass man weiß wie man berechnet wie man
steuern berechnet da gibt es medizin als
frage die man haben geklärt haben möchte
da gibt es politische fragestellungen
und aus diesem kontext heraus wird dann
ein wissen das sich selbst generiert
dass sich fortsetzt und das noch den
gründen fragt und was auch theologisch
motiviert ist aber nicht nur insofern
sind aus der antike mathematik
astronomie medizin und philosophie die
großen profiler der wissenschaft also
das heißt dass ein neuer staat der sich
aufmacht jahr zu breiten an macht zu
gewinnen an einfluss zu gewinnen
bedürfnisse hat in den wissenschaften im
denken die er aus der philosophie
abholen kann auf jeden fall und das
entwickelt dann immer mehr eine art
eigenleben und es werden ganze
theoriegebäude entwickelt und das ist ja
auch das spannende dass es eine innere
dynamik gibt in verschiedenen bereichen
der philosophie aber auch in den
wissenschaften und auch in der medizin
natürlichen die sich dann entfällt aber
das würde dann heißen dass eine reine
philosophie nicht der anfang ist sondern
dass es eher eine art von universellem
wissen ist dass man sucht das man
braucht um dieses große land dieses
mächtige land dieses neue land auch
verwalten zu können zu organisieren
es ist teil dieses großen komplexes von
wissen dass weitergegeben wird
das praktische steht wahrscheinlich am
anfang im vordergrund dafür gibt es
verschiedene beispiele also die erste
besetzung aus dem griechischen ins
arabische war die übersetzung der
steuerlisten und danach kommen
politische traktate auch das comedy
ziehen traktate bei der medizin kommt
die logik als die methode der
wissenschaften und sobald man die logik
als thema hat wird natürlich nachgefragt
wie das spiel in die anderen bereiche
und durch die theologie kommt die frage
nach metaphysik kommt die frage nach
welterklärung noch physik das ist ein
prozess der sich entwickelt die
übersetzungen dauernd etwa 200 jahre
also wir dürfen nicht von einem kleinen
moment ausgehen sondern von einer
periode des großen interesses der großen
neugierde und der eröffnung die zahl der
übersetzungen ist auch immens und diese
übersetzung wie muss man sich das
vorstellen
das sind in einer von einer
universität ausgegangen die sind von
einer politischen macht ausgegangen
die gesellschaft war mehrsprachig
ohnehin das gab das griechische noch was
im alltag gesprochen wurde das gab das
aramäische der syrische das arabische
jetzt zum teil waren es initiativen die
ausgingen nur von dem machthaber selbst
also im auftrag des kalifen
aber wir müssen uns eine breite
gesellschaft vorstellen in der viele
mediziner tätig gewesen sind
die übersetzer oft christen weil sie
mehrsprachig warnt griechisch syrisch
arabisch zum teil aber auch anderen
religionen angehören
was wir dann parade religionen nennen
gibt es durchaus auch aber die
adressaten und die auftraggeber sitzen
in der verwaltung in der neuen
gesellschaft unter denjenigen das reich
organisieren und die einen wissens wird
auf haben und dem nun gestellt sehen
wollen durch das bestmögliche wissen was
verfügbar ist die übersetzungs tradition
setzt sich dann übrigens natürlich in
europa fort also man hat übersetzungs
zentren etwa in spanien und sizilien und
dort werden dann arabische texte
rezitiert sehr spannend aus dem
hebräischen ins arabische und dann ins
lateinische also es gibt vielfältige
weisende aneignung dieser texte
man darf sich das also nicht so
vorstellen dass man irgendwie hier die
islamische welt hätte und dort die
christliche welt
es gab viele überlappungen
überschneidungen und interesse für die
jeweils andere kultur also das heißt man
kann eigentlich wenn ich mir das jetzt
ein bisschen vorstellen sich eine welt
ausmalen damals um 1000 nach christus wo
bagdad im zentrum steht und nach osten
sich ebenso aus weiter nach westen
diese ganze welt weiß ich hat über diese
übersetzungs bewegung über die texte die
ins arabische übersetzt werden ins
arabische weil der koran ist das eine
universelle sprache zur verfügung steht
jetzt heißt das aber dass dann dieses
nein zuerst aus der antike kommt es nach
bagdad und geht dann sofort oder direkt
wieder zurück ist das heißt dass es
immer ein floh ist ein austausch von
anfang an
ja der im übrigen nie aufhört in keiner
der richtung aufhört aber der phasen hat
phasen die besonders stark sind in die
eine oder in die andere richtung
dass die übersetzungen aufhören aus dem
griechischen liegt im wesentlichen daran
dass die texte dann verfügbar sind
es ist nicht so dass wir großartige
lücken hätten in dem programm sondern
das wissensprogramm der spätantike ist
im grunde verfügbar
in der astronomie der tolle - mit all
seinen kommentaren in der medizin gallen
mit all seinen schülern und kommentaren
und vor allen dingen aristoteles in der
philosophie als der große meister mit
den vielen kommentatoren die man von ihm
kennt
nachdem diese surfen da ist und des
korpus da ist arbeitet man damit denn es
geht ja nicht nur darum jetzt zu
verstehen was aristoteles sagt er
sondern die anwendung auf die eigenen
bedürfnisse auf die eigenen neuen
fragestellungen werden dann durchdacht
und so entwickelt sich in ablösung der
reinen kommentierung eine eigene
philosophie auf der grundlage des muss
man durch übersetzungen kennengelernt
hat also das heißt das doch eine art von
mehr leistung nicht nur eine übersetzung
sondern mehr leiste eine philosophische
dann wieder den weg zurückfindet in
unseren westen auf jeden fall denn es
wurden ja nicht nur die übersetzungen
rezipiert sonst immer auch die
kommentare schon jede r besetzung ist
ein versuch überhaupt einen text zu
verstehen da gibt es schwierige passagen
unklare ausdrücke und der übersetzer
versucht dem überhaupt an einen sinn zu
geben und dann kommt der kommentator
hinzu und paraphrasiert zunächst legt
das aus und all das hat man zusammen
gelesen also ich gehe mal ein beispiel
was macht ein autor in paris um 1270 der
hat eine frische übersetzung der
metaphysik aus dem griechischen direkt
ins lateinische
der hat aber auch avéro es der diesen
text schon kommentiert hat in der
arabischen übersetzung und hat noch
andere spätantike kommentare vor sich
und plötzlich findet der 45 angebote um
eine einzige stelle zu
stehen und das entwickelt dann natürlich
seine dynamik dass man sagt aha das kann
man so oder so verstehen und je nachdem
diese oder jene theorie entwickelt
aber wer weiß das stichwort haben sie
gebracht ist einer der wichtigsten
dieser im abendland rezipierten denker
gewesen aber selber ja in cordoba
geboren oder als ein ein lob natürlich
natürlich deshalb ist es eben künstlich
zu sagen es gibt hier die europäische
kultur und dort die auf europäische
kultur sehr viele überlappungen sehr
viele auch kulturelle grenzgebiete in
denen verschiedene kulturbereiche
zusammengekommen sind ja zwei in der
kombination
aber es ist natürlich etwas nach aber es
gibt eine familie mit genealogie die
arabisch ist der wohnort ist spanien ist
andalusien
aber das macht eben nicht zu einem
europäer in einem engeren sinn und das
ist die frage ob dieses prädikat
überhaupt von bedeutung ist und die
zweite bemerkung wir dürfen nicht denken
aus dem westen kommt die philosophie zu
den arabern das griechische erbe ist ein
erbe was im wesentlichen im vorderen
orient längst gepflegt wurde alexandria
ist eigentlich die städte die im
vordergrund steht und diejenigen die in
der spätantike griechischen erbe
gearbeitet haben oder es kommentiert
haben waren zum großteil wieder personen
aus ägypten aus syrien und aus der
region
insofern ist es ein bisschen schwierig
wenn wir griechenland unter westen
subsumieren und sagen von dort kommt das
ist einfach griechenland ist das alte
hellers was ausstrahlt in verschiedene
richtungen und dort ist das eine form
der rezeption von hellenismus die aber
nie als eine rezeption das westliche nur
das europäischen gedacht wird das ist
griechisch aber das was mich dann
einfach integriert hat ist natürlich
diese frage des der eingrenzung also
wenn man einfach grundsätzlich sagt kann
man überhaupt denken eingrenzen
und wenn man von islamischer philosophie
redet hat man natürlich eine form von
eingrenzung oder die man sehr in den
osten setzt jetzt haben wir gespürt
haben dass diese diese bewegungen das
ist ja das faszinierende was etwas
universelles hat also man kann auch 1000
nach christus denken nicht einsperren
auf keinen fall das kann man in keinem
kultur haben würde ich sagen und ich
würde es auch nicht nur auf das
islamische elemente auswählen
also wenn wir den vergleich ziehen was
wir seit der existenz des christentums
haben ist ja auch nicht nur christliche
frauen sondern in einem bestimmten
kultur raum haben sich verschiedene
formen des philosophierens entwickelt
teilweise mehr oder weniger geprägt
durch die religion und das gilt
natürlich auch für andere kulturbereiche
deshalb muss man hier klappt schon
aufpassen dass man nicht alles was in
einem bestimmten kultur angedacht worden
ist gleich reduziert auf eine bestimmte
religion es gibt doch sicher nämlich an
ein breiteres angebot als eine form des
denkens in dieser welt also wir haben
jetzt aber ruhig genannt aber es gibt
sicher dann auch den zweiten großen
sender
und wie verhält wie verhalten sich diese
verschiedensten positionen sphären zu
einander vielleicht nur in ergänzung zu
der frage der religionen ja in der
philosophie in der islamischen bereich
sind natürlich auch christen und juden
genau sein tätig also das ist ohnehin
ein komplex der mann nicht auf einer
zuordnung reduzieren kann
jetzt gibt es verschiedene entwürfe
verschiedene verstehens weisen dass
aristotelischen airbus und dessen
anwendung auf islamische fragestellungen
effizienter macht das sehr stark von der
metaphysik hier hat ein sehr waches auge
in bezug auf religiöse fragestellungen
auch er hat religiöse phänomene
thematisiert auch in seiner philosophie
etwa die frage was ist prophetie was wir
nun griechische auto auch nicht
unbedingt beschäftigt hat aber das hat
der philosophisch durchleuchtet wie
könnte man profitiert beispielsweise
erklären rationale klingen wie hat er
das gemacht hat drei angebot gemacht er
hat gesagt es gibt zum einen die
möglichkeit dass wir nicht nur im traum
und dinge vorstellen sondern dass
bestimmte personen eine so starke
vorstellungskraft haben dass sie ihm
wach sein
bilder und vorstellungen empfangen das
eine möglichkeit dann hat er gesagt es
gibt die möglichkeit dass wir mit
unseren seelischen fähigkeiten vermögen
auf körperliches wirken dass die frage
der wunder propheten vollbringen wunder
jesus wird man wunder im neuen testament
die erklärung die effizienter gibt ist
das seelische befindlichkeiten eine
wirkung haben auf den eigenen körper und
auf andere körper noch hinzu dritte
möglichkeit propheten verstehen wissen
unglaublich schnell sie haben intuition
das heißt sie müssen nicht wie
philosophen das hat er ganz interessant
erklärt die wege durchschreiten indem
sie schritt für schritt sei logisch muss
für sie logisch nachvollziehbar sie
erfassen dass auf einmal intuition das
hat er übrigens für sich selbst der auch
beansprucht die fähigkeit zu haben aber
das spricht er den propheten als
möglichkeit zu und damit sind die in ein
universum integriert auch das denken und
das entscheidende daran ist ja dass man
versucht die dieses beispiel schön zeigt
eine rationale erklärung für profil zu
geben also man nicht einfach an
als etwas was wir halt akzeptieren
müssen sondern versucht das einzubauen
er eine gesamt erklärung indem man sagt
es gibt halt bestimmte kausalen
mechanismen oder es gibt bestimmte
vermögen und wenn wir erst mal verstehen
was diese vermögen sind dann können wir
auch wissen wie ein prophet überhaupt
handeln kann und das hat mir sehr
typisch zu sein für jede form des
philosophierens dass man darüber
nachdenkt was eine gute erklärung können
wir für ein bestimmtes phänomen
überhaupt geben und vielleicht ein
weiterer punkt die philosophie lebt
natürlich auch von der kritik das heißt
es werden nicht einfach nur systeme
errichtet sondern spätere philosophen
greifen etwas berühren auf kritisieren
ist habe was ich gebe ein beispiel ein
philosoph alle raser harley hat ein buch
geschrieben mit dem titel die inkohärenz
der philosophie wo er gesagt haben und
sehen was die behaupten thesen die
überhaupt nicht belegt werden können das
ist etwas das werk und gibt oder so
etwas
und da wäre es ein nachfolger hat dann
die in karenz kritisiert und ein buch
geschrieben mit dem titel die in karenz
die in krems und genauso macht
philosophie fortschritte die man sich
kritisch mit argumenten von vorgängen
auseinander setzt jetzt will ich sie
fragen glaube sie sind
islamwissenschaftler sie sind philosoph
und setzen sich seit langer zeit sehr
intensiv nicht nur sie bei ihnen mit der
islamischen philosophie auseinander wie
ist das eigentlich dazu gekommen also
wie beginnt man sich zu interessieren
für das was vor
ja gedacht wurde also bei mir war das so
ein witziges erlebnis ich habe ganz am
anfang meines studiums in fribourg
zufällig ein buch in die hand gekriegt
dass dieses buch über den apfel und das
ist eine mischung aus arabischen märchen
platonischen dialog und eine prise
aristoteles
es geht darum dass aristoteles auf dem
sterbebett liegt und dann wird eben so
ein süßer duftende apfel hingehalten und
das hält die noch am leben und in seinen
letzten minuten berichtet er seinen
jüngern wie es sich verhält mitte seele
und der unsterblichkeit der seele und
ich fand dass unglaublich faszinierend
zu sehen
ja da ist ein text rezipiert worden im
westen
der bringt platonische elemente reihen
die damals im westen gar nicht bekannt
waren dann so märchen elemente und all
das wurde auf raffinierte art und weise
gemischt und das hat dann meine neugier
geweckt dann sagte ich da ist
irgendetwas was ich nicht gekannt habe
in der so genannten rein westlichen
philosophie und ich will verstehen
welchen beitrag das auch geleistet hat
zur fortentwicklung der westlichen
flügel bei der ein ansatzpunkt war das
interesse an der region und an der
sprache vor allen dingen ich habe
relativ früh arabisch gelernt mit dem
wunsch zu verstehenden texte zu lesen
es ist sehr schwierig an habe ich zu
lernen ja und nein das ist nicht
schwieriger als andere sprachen raus ist
ein völlig neues system und es gibt uns
natürlich die möglichkeit auch über
unser eigenes denken nach zu denken
wiederum im sinne von inwiefern hängt
das mit der sprache zusammen also
inwiefern ist unsere logik ein ausdruck
unserer eigenen sprachsysteme
germanischen im falle spezielles
griechischen wenn man sagen könnte dass
die kritische logica vorbild und gewesen
ist inwiefern ist die arabische sprache
etwas was ein anderes denken
transportiert artikuliert und vielleicht
auch andere möglichkeiten der zuordnung
in der sprache gibt so das ist etwas
ganz spannende diskussionen gab im
zehnten jahrhundert ist logik von
aristotle das wirklich logik für alle
menschen oder ist das nur die regeln für
die griechische sprache und wären nicht
die logik für die araber die arabische
grammatik die man deren lernen müssten
ganz sparen der diskussion mit beiden
standpunkten in denen sich durchgesetzt
hat dass logik im sinne des aristoteles
etwas universales sei das also
denkstrukturen universal sein und man an
diesem projekt des aristoteles
weiterarbeiten könnte was für diese
mischung widerspricht und wie ist es
denn die begriffsbestimmung der
philosophie im arabischen unterscheidet
sich unser es gibt eine die ist
rezipiert und das ist ein lehnwort im
arabischen heißt einfach falls es ist
eine übernahme des griechischen begriff
dann gibt es den begriff weisheit im
arabischen raum sehr wichtig der
manchmal missverstanden wird als ein
gegenüber zu falstaff also als eine
orientalische weisheit oder so etwas das
ist aber gar nicht so gemeint sondern
das ist tatsächlich die alte sapientia
in ganz ähnlicher auslegung wie sie auch
im westen gedacht worden ist also ein
umfassendes wissen philosophie ja nicht
verstanden nur als methodenlehre für die
anderen wissenschaften sondern als ein
umfassendes wissen was die theoretischen
wissenschaften und die praktischen ja
hinsicht nicht ähnliches gilt über
gesagt für die sogenannte westliche
philosophie es gibt ja nicht einfach den
philosophie begriffen schon das ist ein
streit was haben wir überhaupt unter
philosophie zu verstehen
und da gibt es konkurrierende angebote
philosophie als weisheitslehren
philosophie aber auch erstmals
metaphysik als etwas was bildlich
gesprochen über den empirischen
wissenschaften steht und darüber
nachdenkt was eigentlich die
grundbegriffe sein sollen die wir dann
in den empirischen wissenschaften
verwenden aber auch philosophie die eng
an die theologie gebunden ist als eine
sogenannte natürliche theologie und dann
werden fragen gestellt wie können wir
die existenz gottes beweisen was ist
gott überhaupt
oder was gibt es sonst noch für
überirdische kräfte
all das hat auch platz gehabt in
philosophie begriff im mittelalter und
früher neuzeit auch im westlichen hoffen
sie haben zusammen ein buch geschrieben
vor rund zehn jahren 2000 über den
sogenannten akkus und casio malliß muss
was hat es damit auf sich
das ist ein besonderer fall insofern ist
jetzt da nicht um eine kritische theorie
geht die sich weiterentwickelt und wo
man die arabischen entwürfe als eine
fortsetzung der spätantike deuten könnte
sondern es ist etwas was in der
arabischen theologie islamischen
theologie neu entworfen wurde dann aber
gleichwohl seinen weg nach europa
gefunden hat auf ungewöhnlichen kanälen
und mit ungewöhnliche rezeption konkret
vielleicht kann ich ja mal ein beispiel
er also wir gehen im alltag davon aus
dass es so etwas wie ursachen gibt zum
beispiel wenn ich dieses glas anhebe bin
ich die ursache für diese bewegung und
viele haben dann gemeint naja dann
musste es irgendwo versteckte kausale
kräfte geben wir sehen die zwar nicht
aber die wirken irgendwie und dann haben
arabische theologen und philosophen
gefragt was berechtigt uns eigentlich
solche kräfte anzunehmen
wir sehen ja nur die wirkung aber wir
sehen nicht die kausale kraft die was
tut könnte es nicht sein dass einfach
gott handelt das also das was wir für
eine natürliche ursache handeln nichts
anderes als gott ist er wirkt das wäre
dann nur eine gelegenheit für das
göttliche handel deshalb wo casio und
journalismus
das scheint auf den ersten blick erst
mal absuchen zu sein warum sollten wir
annehmen dass gott alles tools und wir
sozusagen nur rumliegen in der welt aber
das raffiniert daran ist dass man dann
darüber nachdenkt was eigentlich eine
ursache ist und ob wir wirklich
berechtigt sind so was wie versteckte
kräfte anzunehmen und das hat eine
riesen debatte ausgelöst
dann auch im westen bis weit in die
neuzeit hinein
also das heißt das vor allem
überraschend ist dass das was wir denken
dass mit kant eingeführt wird nicht
eingeführt wurde von kann sondern
mehrere hundert jahre vorher in der
islamischen philosophie und auf jeden
fall also in diesen praktischen falk
hätte man sagen ist kant ein punkt in
einer langen kette einer theoretischen
debatten und qantas aufgenommen von
vorgängen aus dem 17 jahrhundert die
wiederum geprägt waren von
mittelalterlichen autoren und da sieht
man auch sehr schön wie dann plötzlich
ein problem den ausschlag das ergibt
dass man eine ganze theorie umbaut also
man nicht mehr annimmt das gibt jetzt
kausaler kräfte sondern sagt wir müssen
vorsichtig sein wir können nur
beschreiben
immer wenn wir das sehen sehen wir auch
das aber ob es dazwischen so eine
magische kraft gibt die das verbindet
ist etwas was sie nicht sagen können und
deshalb sollten wir erstmal tierisch
genau vorgehen und beobachten was es in
der welt gibt und was dahintersteckt
dafür können wir verschiedene mit einer
physischen modelle geben also wir haben
richtig dass ein bisschen wieder
zusammenführen also jetzt ausgelegt
haben wenn wir sagen wir haben also
einen impuls der kommt als dieser
islamischen welt seiner durch nach
europa es gibt eine hochblüte dieser
islamischen denkens und wenn man das ein
bisschen pauschalisiert dann scheint das
irgendwo abzubrechen nach verona ist tot
und man hat eigentlich sind das gefühl
danach passiert dann lange also
überhaupt nichts mehr dass das ist ja
nicht der fall
es ändert sich einiges ändert sich
einiges in der zuordnung und in der
regionalen entwicklung innerhalb der
islamischen welt und das ändert sich das
parat ich war konkret bis dorthin ist
aristoteles eigentlich der meister den
mann erklärt und an dem man entlang
theorien weiterentwickelt aber wo es ist
da ja geradezu ein musterfall der
zurückkehrt auch eine nahe beziehung zu
aristoteles insofern etwa 14 kritisiert
al ghazali kritisiert das hatten wir
vorher gesehen dass sie sich von
aristoteles entfernt also erst quasi der
der wächter des aristotelis muss
derjenige der ist noch einmal auf den
punkt bringt das was in der islamischen
welt ist auch der kühle redet der
rationalistischen denker als das was wir
in avid als welt der intuition
da das hinein zu verlieren also man
könnte auch sagen als der dogmatische
denke und dahin wird er dem aristotelis
muss sehr eng folgt und der seine
begriffe von dort relativ unverändert
natürlich könnte man sprechen
abwandlungen auch formuliert effizienter
bezieht sich auch darauf noch
effizienter nimmt andere punkte heraus
beispielsweise die frage der intuition
die offizielle thematisiert die sieht ja
nicht als anti aristotelis sondern die
sie das auslegen und dessen was
aristoteles als scharf sind bezeichnet
das gibt ein begriff bei rees brückl es
schaffst du ihn also das unmittelbare
direkte erfassen das legte aus und
bringt einen neuen kontext und macht es
auf diese art und weise fruchtbar wie es
bei aristoteles jetzt nie gedacht war
aber das ist gleichwohl etwas was daran
entwickelt ist und was nicht irrational
ist sondern intuition ist im grunde der
höhepunkt von rationalität man versteht
sofort klar diese dinge nun im
dreizehnten jahrhundert ist es in der
islamischen welt so dass effizient zu
muster wird zum paradigma für die
weitere wieder so viel es gibt dann
keine aristoteles kommentare mehr
aber es gibt auch die zehner kommentaren
und das in großer zahl
einerseits sind das wirklich direkt
kommentare zu seinen werken zu zwei
hauptwerken von ihm
andererseits gibt es inzwischen die
institution wasser und an der hochschule
muss man philosophie natürlich lehren
können
zu diesem zweck gibt es
zusammenfassungen zusammenfassung der
philosophie avid senders die dann als
handbuch erscheinen
kleinere längere opfern reiche was wir
sehen welche 13 teams und von da an
haben wir einen aktionismus so müsste
man das beschreiben in der islamischen
welt regional vor allen dingen im osten
nicht so sehr im westen im westen gibt
es noch in madrid gewisse folgen von
avéro ist aber diese blüte des
antizionismus hatte ihren mittelpunkt in
iran irak syrien und geht dann über
jahrhunderte dort und bringt wiederum
verschiedene entwicklungen hervor wie
zeller dann ausgelegt werden kann ist
der stark theologisch sehr stark
rational oder auch in verbindung mit
mystik und sufismus also es endlich
wieder eine mehrzahl von nationalitäten
das ist auch sehr wichtig für die
westliche wahrnehmung arabischen
philosophie denn solange der addition
ist uns im vordergrund steht ist das für
viele westliche leser wenig interessant
die sich immer mehr auf aristoteles
stürzen denn wir durch schlicht
vergessen dass die westliche philosophie
gerade ab dem 13 jahrhundert sehr stark
sich mit aristoteles auseinandersetzte
erstmal positiv und danach dem 17
jahrhundert immer mehr negativ aber
aristoteles war sozusagen der klassiker
an die man sich gerieben hat und weniger
effizienter und das führte glaube ich
auch dazu dass man die weitere
entwicklung im arabischen raum weniger
wahrgenommen hat ganz einfach weil man
eigeninteressen hatte die man weiter
verfolgen wollte noch mehr gilt das für
die zeit nach dem 17 jahrhundert wo es
nicht zuletzt durch eine
wissenschaftliche entwicklung und
spricht er häufig von wissenschaftliche
revolution dazu gekommen ist das
plötzlich neue methoden auch neue
probleme im vordergrund standen
man könnte sagen der besten war so mit
sich selbst beschäftigt und mit den
eigenen umweltzonen dass er das was sich
auch weiterentwickelt hat aber in
anderer form gar nicht zur kenntnis
genommen hat aber es könnte schon
natürlich so sein wir haben gesagt diese
blüte oder dass das wirklich so
dynamisch und schnell und und
fantastisch von von sich geht das was
von bagdad aus passiert dass das mit
einer macht mit geld mit potenz zu tun
hat so meines eines reichs eines staates
der bedürfnisse hat jetzt gibt es
irgendwann mal die probleme im osten
also politisch gesehen oder gegen die
mongolen und es gibt im westen probleme
dieses reichert probleme also verliert
sich auch die potenz des denkens der
status der mongolen ist ein sehr
spannender
es wird oft in der geschichtsschreibung
so getan als hätten die mongolen alles
zerstört vor allem den auch kultur und
wissenschaft nichts gespürt das ist also
das siehst du 12 512 58 bestätigung
grund erobert und dann ist die
mongolische herrschaft über jahrhunderte
wenn wir noch timo wirth hinzunehmen und
seine nachfolger tja
noch weiter teile erobert hatten dann
spielt das eine rolle über zwei
jahrhunderte in der islamischen welt
die erste reaktion war eine ganz
interessante insofern die bestehenden
religionen näher aneinander gerückt sind
die mongolische herrscher war ein
fremder auch mit einer fremd religion
und wir haben nirgends so interessante
traktate des vergleichen zwischen
islamischer christlicher jüdischer
theologie im 13 jahrhundert gegenüber
diesem gemeinsamen feind vorläufig
gesagt oder jedenfalls diesem außen
etwas unbestreitbaren andersdenkenden
das ändert sich die mongolen verkehren
sich dann sehr schnell zum islam dann
wird es auch eine islamische herrschaft
die habt und ein hohes interesse an
wissenschaft philosophie und mathematik
blühen in dieser zeit und blühen im
mongolischen reich wir haben etwa auch
dann die finanziellen möglichkeiten
sternwarten von ungeahnter größe
messinstrumente von ungeahnter
genauigkeit im norden irans später in
seiner hand und kann sich markant heute
noch instrumente sehen die damals gebaut
wurden mit einer größe mit einem aufwand
und einer genauigkeit die nirgendwo
anders auf der welt erreicht wurden
insofern haben wir auch da durchaus mit
senaten tun und ein interesse und eine
gesellschaft die offen für wissenschaft
ist was übrigens später dann sind wir
dann muss man auch erstmal fortsetzen
aber trotzdem also das haben sie vorher
gesagt wenn man die welt nochmals
aufteilt und entschuldigen sie diese
einfache konstellation aber in die in
den westen oder osten in aber so riss
und ineffizienter dass sich der osten
richtige richtung allee center
entwickelt und lässt damit sich selbst
beschäftigt ist und noch spuren von
avoriaz mitnimmt dass hier eine trennung
sich vollzieht dass man dass man so doch
quasi zur parallel universen hat die
aber nicht mehr wirklich interagieren
gehen aber ich würde sagen das hat mit
dem nächsten mindestens so viel zu
erklären wie radio show überarbeitet
wird also da dürfte nichts sagen und
dieses vorurteil gibt es ja manchmal
dann kommt zu einem verfall oder einer
dekadenz im arabischen raum unterdessen
blüht auf das halte ich für verfehlt das
ist ja so dass es natürlich dann neue
intellektuelle zentren gab auch im
westen also wir dürfen nicht vergessen
ab dem 13 jahrhundert etabliert sich das
was sie heute noch
die universität wird es gibt starke
universitäre zentren etwa in paris und
es wird und die bilden natürlich ihre
eigenen schulen definieren ihre eigenen
probleme
ich bin spätestens im 17 jahrhundert als
dann auch die physik einen großen
aufschwung erlebte und andere
naturwissenschaften gab es immer mehr
forschungszentren im westen und
natürlich auch entsprechende politische
macht die das ganze stabilisiert hat
deshalb denke ich war der westen auch so
sehr mit sich selber beschäftigt und hat
weniger wahrgenommen was ist ein trick
proben auch außerhalb des öffentlichen
raums gab aber es ist ja schon auch
interessant also wenn dann sagt zum
beispiel venedig oder also wenn man
durch venedig spaziert ist man auf
schritt und tritt mit einer magischen
vergangenheit konfrontiert dass man den
eindruck hat dass dieser dieses hin und
her dieses auch wenn das nicht nur immer
freundschaftlich war dass man dass
bibliotheken geplündert hat und und das
wissen wieder zu sich geholt hat das
wieso ist dieses interesse plötzlich
abgeflacht dann bei uns wenn man denkt
ja wenn die diesen spannend ist wieder
machen
das ist ja nicht wirklich abgeflacht
also in der renaissance hat man aber wo
ist noch mehr gelernt als im mittelalter
das ist eine sache die noch nicht
wirklich erforscht ist in vielen
einzelheiten aber es gibt mehr
übersetzungen von avéro es ins
lateinische in der zeit der renaissance
nennen als ich spielte eine rolle und
das schauen aber das ist doch die die
früher rezeption das ist quasi das
auslaufen des dreizehnten jahrhundert
dann sind etwa 150 jahre kaum neue
übersetzung ist lateinische da aber dann
wieder mit großen vorab 1470 80 ist in
16 jahrhundert hinein
da wird mehr avéro ist übersetzt ins
lateinische als im 13 jahrhundert rein
von der anzahl der texte insofern ist
das paradigma noch da und da spielt im
übrigen die überlieferung über das
hebräische eine ganz starke rolle dass
in jüdische gelehrte jüdischer wussten
es wird oft aus dem hebräischen ins
lateinische übersetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt aber die frage ist natürlich
berechtigt warum ging es da nicht so
weiter also warum hat man sich nicht
dann auch in späteren jahrhunderten in
der gleichen form ganz intensiv
nicht beschäftigt und ich glaube wieder
das hat was mit den entwicklungen nach
dem westen zu tun also ich gebe nur ein
beispiel
die reformation und die gegenreformation
führt natürlich dazu dass es auch
plötzlich sozusagen brodelte im westen
und dass man zurückgeworfen wurde auf
die eigene auch religiöse tradition und
versuche unternommen hat die neu zu
interpretieren mit allen
auseinandersetzungen die damit einher
gingen
und ich glaube das hat auch etwas
bewirkt also dass man dann sozusagen
vielleicht mehr nach innen geschaut hat
in europa und weniger wahrgenommen hat
was man hätte lernen können auch aus
außer europäischen bereich hinzu kommen
dass die grenzen andere sind also der
bereich andalusien mit wechselnden
grenzen über jahrhunderte und
kontaktzonen der ist ab einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt nicht mehr ein austausch
bereich übrigens vor wenn man von der
philosophie einmal abstrahiert und auf
anderes kommt in der kunst etwa also sie
haben venedig genannt bauwerke die sind
sehr stark inspiriert von islamischer
formensprache und da ist das aus
andalusien sehr wohl wiederum rezipiert
worden sehr weit in europa erst mal in
spanien selbst dann darüber hinaus auch
also da geht schon einen kontakt weiter
aber in diesem falle nicht auf die
philosophie bezogen sizilien ist
wirklich gefallen sie zieren war die
große kontaktzone und friedrich der
zweite von hohenstaufen konnte arabisch
sein reich war auf einem vorher
arabischen gebiet errichtet hatte
gelehrte am hoch die mehrere dieser
sprachen konnten
also das sind auch momente in denen die
bedingungen von außen dafür gesprochen
haben dass die rezeption sehr stark sein
konnte abgesehen von der inneren
entwicklung dieser ständig eine rolle
spielt im islamischen bereich muss man
hinzufügen dass da kommen die mongolen
wieder ins spiel die sie erwähnt haben
das zentrum das machtzentrum und die
orientierung natürlich deutlich nach
osten gewandert ist
durch die mongolen kommt die kontakte
sehr stark nach china
im übrigen auch nach indien empfohlen
der oberlin ländern sehr schnell auch
und wir haben das islamische indien
bedienen
die ersten übungen sehr früh aber in
wirklichkeit ab dem dreizehnten
jahrhundert ist das eine starke
entwicklung der macht islamischer seitz
in indien
da gibt es dann wiederum austausch und
das betrifft jetzt europa nicht aber
dass die islamische welt ist ja eine
breite welt die in sich sehr stark
vernetzt ist die viele kontakte
untereinander hat allein das ist ja
schon etwas der marokkaner der mit dem
man außer markant spricht weil er in
mekka getroffen hat in indien jetzt wo
eine neue rezeption stattfindet in beide
richtungen
da haben die muslime sich interessiert
für das was indische wissenschaft ist
was indische religion ist was englische
medizin ist und haben übersetzt jetzt
aus indischen sprache aus dem sanskrit
jetzt persische vor allen dingen das ist
etwas was wir auch noch kaum erforscht
haben ab dem dreizehnten jahrhundert
schwerpunkt 16 17 jahrhundert also aus
moosen gibt es immer wieder und
dynamiken sind unterschiedlich und wir
können sie nicht zu allen zeiten aber
überall vergleichbar aber nehmen wir
noch mal schnell unsere unsere
europäische position ein bisschen
irgendwo so ab dem 13 jahrhundert und
wir beginnen irgendwo so ein bisschen
den den kontakt zu verlieren denn das
den geistigen wer wen wir beschäftigen
uns mit uns selber ja und das gefühl
aber das dass wir diese diese linie auch
kappen also wenn man das anstandsgefühl
ist gekommen danach ideologische bereits
ideologische probleme mit hinzu dass man
irgendwie beginnt auf einem auge langsam
blind zu werden und dass man auch
inhalte mit diesem samstag zu nehmenden
ignoranz von dem was da im osten
passiert verbindet und vermischt
in der tat und das hat sicher damit zu
tun dass man ja lange zeit so etwas wie
ein gemeinsames projekt hat solange man
zb gemeinsam aristoteles kommentiert hat
versuchte man diesen schwierigen auto zu
verstummen wenn das einmal aufhört dann
wird es natürlich schwierig überhaupt
einen gemeinsamen bezugspunkt zu haben
und dann kommen diese ideologischen
momente hin zu zb das bedürfnis nach
einer klaren abgrenzung des christentums
gegenüber anderen religionen was auch
wieder mit einer christlichen
kontroversen zu tun hat dass man
sozusagen wie den eigenen stand
festklopfen will und dann grenzt man
sich gegenüber anderen aber es ist doch
auch ein kraftakt immer gesagt das sind
ja mehrere jahrhunderte von einfluss
oder von von gemeinsamen vergangenheit
im südwesten von europa auf dem balkan
islam ist eine europäische religion
unser vieh und plötzlich beginnt das
dann nicht mehr zustimmen und also ich
würde sagen es ist ein schleichender
braucht ja aber natürlich ist es ein
prozess der dazu führt dass man auch
andere weltregionen plötzlich in den
blick nimmt also wir dürfen ja auch
nicht vergessen ab dem 16 jahrhundert
wurde kolonialisiert europa war mit
nord- und südamerika beschäftigt hat
china entdeckt und hat sich auch mit
anderen kulturräumen beschäftigt und das
führte dazu dass man jetzt mehrere
partner hatte auf den austausch und sich
nicht will diesen einen partner so sehr
interessiert hat wie das noch in den 500
jahren davor der fall war
ja und dann die reformation für haben
kurz gesprochen ist ist so eine
eine zäsur eine reformation im
islamischen raum gibt es so nicht nicht
in demselben sind wir verbinden mit
reformation der bestimmte erwartungen
und setzen die dann auch quasi in einem
perioden zusammenhang dass wir sagen es
gibt ein mittelalter dann gibt es eine
periode die renaissance nennen dann
kommt die reformation vergleichbare
abfolgen dürfen wir nicht erwarten
sollten wir auch gar nicht erwarten weil
das natürlich nur hießen wir vergleichen
auf eine art und weise dass wir den
europäischen leisten über andere
schlagen elemente von reform und von
nachdenken über die grundlagen der
religion hat das natürlich gegeben in
der islamischen welt
die allerdings nicht in vergleichbare
politische prozesse eingewoben waren und
die dann auch nicht diese folge hatten
wie man sie in europa beobachten kann im
16 und 17 jahrhundert dass sich an
dieser debatte dann sehr vieles
weiterentwickelt hat und dass hier
fragestellung neu aufgeworfen worden
sind die dann auch in bezug auf
das beispiel mit der ausdehnung also
europa wirft die anker aus waren das
sind das ist ja alles eine ein zeitalter
wo sich verschiedene aspekte von
ökonomischer und religiöser geschichte
verbinden europa das gibt es so in der
islamischen welt nicht die idee vorhaben
von indien gesprochen also das gibt ja
diese bewegung den osten
bei uns ist den westen war es noch
westlicher amerika also das hätte ja
durchaus dann am schluss seine eine
gemeinsamkeit eine ganz zeit geben
können rund um den erdball und das ist
ja auch geworden also der dfb zumindest
jetzt in der in der neueren zeit und ab
da vorbereitet ist ja in einem
globalisierung eingetreten die
tatsächlich auch dazu führt dass die
kontakte zwischen diesen verschiedenen
bereichen enorm hoch gewesen sind die
mobilität auch da wieder enorm hoch
gewesen ist übrigens auch islamischer
seitz also ein beispiel zu nennen
es gab den sechzehnten jahrhundert einen
islamischen sultan in sumatra weit weg
als der von den portugiesen angegriffen
wurde hat er sich an die osmanen gewandt
und hat gesagt könnt ihr mir helfen
woraufhin die auswahl eine forte
schickten nach sumatra
und dann haben sie gegen die portugiesen
dort gewonnen in einer schlacht die
niemand kennt hier
wie heißt die schlacht einfach das gilt
auch jetzt keine rolle für unsere
geschichte lehre dass wir den lern- und
der als etwas das bei sumatra direkt bei
agip aber die die akteure waren da und
auch die auswahl akteure in diesem
bereich dieses ist globalisierung ja ein
interessantes phänomen das erleben wir
auch heute wieder und irgendwie ein
phänomen mit zwei dimensionen zum einen
gibt es natürlich dieses
weltumspannenden man versucht
verschiedene kulturen zusammenzubringen
aber es gibt auch die gegenläufige
tendenz dass man sich abschottet dass
man versucht die eigene identität zu
wahren oder vielleicht erst mal zu
bestimmen und das phänomen findet man
auch schon im westen also ab dem 17
jahrhundert je mehr man sich überspitzt
gesagt bedroht fühlte durch diese
anderen kulturen die plötzlich auch
präsent waren desto mehr hat man
versucht das eigene westliche genau zu
bestimmen und sich dann auch immer mehr
als würdig
den osten gelten also wenn wir jetzt den
perspektivenwechsel noch einmal machen
also der ganzen westlichen modernen
revolutionen und die dynamik die sich
hier entwickelt und gibt das dann so
etwas wie und wo man sagt ihnen in der
islamischen arabischen welt da geht die
post ab und jetzt müssen wir schauen was
die machen um das wieder zurückzuholen
also ist da die abschottung nicht schon
etwas was sich abzeichnet von derzeit
sprechen ich würde sagen also ich 18 19
da haben wir aber andere bedingungen
andere historische bedingungen das ist
sehr wichtig entwicklungen die wir etwa
also als reform denken beschreiben
können gibt es im islamischen welt es
gibt auch entwicklungen im sinne von
nachdenken über das was man eigentlich
tut was wir als aufklärung beschreiben
also die selbst aufklärung der eigenen
position da gibt es durchaus denke die
darüber geschrieben haben da gibt es
versuche neue bewertungen zu finden
nur sind wir ab dem 18 jahrhundert
spätestens in einem politischen kontext
in dem die islamische welt deutlich im
hintertreffen ist aus ökonomischen
gründen und anderen gegebenheiten die
eine große rolle
das wird aber auch so wahrgenommen der
islamischen das wird so wahrgenommen das
wird wahrgenommen also die die
überlegungen das waren reformen braucht
gehen wir mal auf die politische seite
beginnen im osmanischen reich im späten
16 jahrhundert das ist relativ früh da
haben wir ein magisches reich was noch
sehr erfolgreich ist
was noch gewissermaßen seine größte
ausdehnung vor sich hat und dort den
merkt man schon dass jetzt innerhalb der
verwaltung gewisse dinge nicht ideal
sind und wir haben politische traktate
die darüber nachdenken und die das auch
benennen die also beispielsweise sagen
was hinter die fehler bei uns warum
haben wir jetzt mit den europäern
schwierigkeiten
in ungarn usw warum haben wir weniger
erfolg als vorher und die dann sagen
unsere regierung hatte als erster fehler
das sehr ungerecht ist ein problem der
gerechtigkeit das klingt relativ
aufgeklärt würde ich sagen frage der
beratung in wie weit geht der herrscher
auf andere stände ein und berät sich mit
dem frage dass der modernisierung von
militär und frage der entwicklung von
gesellschaft das sind dinge die
aufgelistet werden wein als politische
fragen und die durchaus ein bewusstsein
von krise auch zeigen zunächst einmal
eine krise in einem wettbewerb politisch
ökonomischen das führt dann dazu im
osmanischen reich dass man zu beginn des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts da gibt es eine
phase und etwa 20 jahren übersetzt aus
europäischen sprachen
weil man versucht jetzt das aufzuholen
und modernisierung quasi durch neue
wissens adaption neues rezipieren von
europäischen tages in einem historischen
bewusstsein dass man das schon mal
gemacht hat durchaus in dem man sogar
alte übersetzungen zum teil korrigiert
interessanterweise die physik des
aristoteles plötzlich wird neu übersetzt
man nimmt man kennt die übersetzung aus
dem neunten jahrhundert und sagt das war
nicht schlecht für damals aber das kann
man heute besser ausdrücken und dann
wird es neu übersetzt also da gibt es
schon
das empfinden und auch das klare urteil
das ein wird darauf besteht was man
jetzt unterschiedlich situieren müsste
in politischer hinsicht ökonomischer
militärischer hinsicht oder
intellektueller
allerdings ist man dermaßen inzwischen
im hintertreffen aufgrund der
ökonomischen erfolge europas und da ist
das 18 19 jahrhundert ja dieser großer
wechsel der vorläufig uneinholbar ist
der nicht nur die islamische welt
sondern alle anderen regionen auch mit
einer übermacht konfrontiert vor allem
ökonomischer art bei dem man nicht
mithalten kann
das führt zu einer neuen komplexität zu
einerseits dem wunsch dass man sehr
schnell sich orientieren das lerne
übersetzte rezipieren aber das ganze
nicht mehr aus einer situation des
souveränen aneignen sondern aus der
situation
der unterlegenheit der unsicherheit in
den tiefen verunsicherung mit all den
fragen die dann an die eigene kultur
gerichtet werden wie konnte das
passieren
sie haben ja ich bin zufrieden
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich genau zu
der zeit auch im westen mindestens zwei
wichtige entwicklungen zum einen dass
man immer mehr sich selber eine
geschichte zurecht legt also zum
beispiel das was wir heute
philosophiegeschichte als akademische
disziplin etabliert sich erst im 19
jahrhundert und das geht damit einher
dass man sich selber die geschichte
zurechtgelegt hat mit dem griechischen
als beginn und dann entwicklungsphasen
bis zur eigenen position und das heißt
man hat anderes sozusagen überspitzt
gesagt auf sich selbst bezogen und auf
sich selbst hin gelesen und was gestört
hat natürlich ausgeblendet und das hat
sehr stark dazu geführt dass europa sich
seine eigene geschichte zurechtgelegt
hat in abgrenzung von anderen gebieten
seine seine als intellektuelle dominant
genug gehabt und eine zweite sehr
wichtige entwicklung in der hoch ist
natürlich die ablösung von der religion
oder genauer gesagt von gewissen
theologischen formen auch der
problemstellung und der
auseinandersetzung also man hat ja lange
zeit viel gemeinsam mit einem anderen
raum in dem religion auch zentral war wo
man ausgehen auch von theologischen
grundfragen und dann modell entwickelt
hat um mit diesen problemen umzugehen
schönredens sprechen sie von der
religion weil da müssen wir glaube ich
wirklich auch noch drauf schauen wenn
wenn ich habe das gelesen das natürlich
dieser schock gegenüber dem westen dass
das auch etwas haben wo man gesagt hat
sich in der arabischen welt ja aber wir
haben durch die vernünftige religion
also wir sind eigentlich die
rationalisten wieso haben die jetzt so
eine dynamik in den wissenschaften und
so weiter und sind so überlegen bis hin
zur kriegsführung und staatswesen also
dass man sich nicht jetzt die arabische
welt vorzustellen hat als eben diese
medizinische versorgung spirituell
es wäre der intuition und das ist dass
der introspektion keineswegs auch er
theologie war zum größten teil
nationalistische zu ludwig das heißt man
hat sich argumente zurechtgelegt um eine
bestimmte position auch in der theologie
zu bestimmen zum beispiel um zu erklären
was sind denn die gewöhnlichen attribute
können wir überhaupt seinen attributen
sprechen und dafür hat man sehr
nationalistisch argumentiert aber was
man natürlich im westen sieht auf den 18
19 jahrhunderts eine tendenz
philosophisches nachdenken davon ab zu
lösen das heißt nicht dass es
verschwunden ist keineswegs aber es gab
den versuch zu sagen lassen wir mal die
theologischen probleme beiseite und
versuchen wir gewisse grundprobleme
unabhängig davon zu klären und dadurch
ging natürlich auch das interesse an
anderen denkformen verloren wo genau
diese nationalistische umgang mit
theologischen problemen im vordergrund
stand die theologischen probleme die
beginnen ja dann auch wieder
navarro ist wo die frage sich gestellt
der sich die frage stellt hat also ist
darf man überhaupt philosophieren
die frage wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe beantwortet hat man muss
philosophieren dass wenn wir jetzt aus
dem heutigen standpunkt dass 2015 diesen
kontext noch mal anschauen und sagen ist
in der islamischen welt heute quasi
immer noch das gebot man muss
philosophieren und in welchem kontext
ist philosophieren möglich das existiert
durchaus noch allerdings sind das
natürlich verschiedener modelle die
heute miteinander konkurrieren es gibt
eine debatte darüber und das
grundproblem dass die frage wer wir sind
und wie konstruiert man seine geschichte
und seine philosophie geschichte auch im
neunzehnten jahrhundert in europa aus
einer position der selbstreferenz
geleistet wurde das heißt man hat
geschaut was haben wir alles getan und
erreicht und hat die kriterien nach
denen man seine eigene identität
definiert an sich selbst gemessen
das ist ein blick auf die eigene
geschichte und auch die eigene
technologie fortschritt zukunft und so
weiter
in der islamischen welt haben wir das
problem dass um diese zeit natürlich
auch darüber nachgedacht wird aber die
referenzrahmen ist nicht mehr nur der
eigene sondern plötzlich dieser
vergleich und dieser vergleich ist so
heftig und geschieht aus der position
der unterlegenheit heraus dass wie sie
angedeutet haben die grundfrage was ist
denn unser islam und was leistet er als
erklärung dabei gestellt werden musste
damit wird das philosophische denken zu
einem was politisch belastet ist das
heißt die philosophie soll etwas mit
erklären was politisch geschehen ist
oder auch die region so etwas mit
erklären insofern man dann solche
modelle aufgeworfen hat wie damals
hatten wir viel erfolg damals war es der
reine der ursprüngliche islam also muss
man zum reinen islam zurückkehren und
dann kommen auch wieder erfolg haben
solche sehr einfachen schlüssel sind
gezogen worden
diese debatte ist bei uns ganz stark
angekommen und wir nehmen die islamische
welt der gegenwart als einer an die nur
noch darüber diskutiert das ist aber
nicht der fall
die dinge die geschehen sind sind auf
der einen seite eine betonung des
religiösen bis hin zum islamistischen
und auf der anderen seite einen kritik
und das ist eine akademische philosophie
strömung oder ist es das ist eine die
versucht akademisch zu sein
das ist einer die natürlich politisch
sehr stark wird die wir auch hier in die
ideologie schublade stecken würden und
damit ganz gut bezeichnen aber die sehr
wohl auch akademiker interessiert in der
akademischen philosophie sind die
debatten sehr breit und die farben nun
als grundthema braucht man überhaupt
religion so wie sie es dann
und da gibt es zwei antworten es gibt
die versuche religion neu zu lesen und
mit der religion etwas zu finden was wir
als moderne bezeichnen würden
verbunden mit einer kritik auch der
eigenen tradition verbunden mit auch
eine kritik europas und des
kolonialismus
das ist die eine möglichkeit die andere
ist das rein rational vorgehen
das heißt zu sagen wir müssen aufhören
mit diesem selbstbezug es ist doch gar
nicht sinnvoll dass wir solche fragen
beispiel der religion erörtern sondern
das sind völlig andere faktoren die eine
rolle spielen
da geht es um gesellschaftliche
entwicklung da geht es um soziale fragen
da geht es um historische entwicklung
die wir auf eine andere art und weise
beschreiben müssen
das sind positionen die bis heute sehr
stark sind
das zweite übrigens noch viel mehr als
in europäischen oder amerikanischen
universität mit linken debatten
verbunden mit marxistischen positionen
ist heute die mit religion und gerade
gar nichts argumentieren sondern sie
sagen das ist genau der fehler den die
araber machen dass sie meinen wir müssen
an der religion arbeiten und dann kommt
der erfolg und auf diese art und weise
ein komplex von ideologie herstellen der
nichts anderes ist als das sich
absperren dass sich einigeln und das
irrationale das nicht argumentieren
also haben wir eine lebhafte debatte von
denen nur wenige stimmen bis zu uns nach
europa kommen also das heißt dass die
bosse islamisch die findet statt die
findet nicht nur in der arabischen welt
statt die findet auch bei uns statt
nehmen schaden so ist es das fließend
ist das sind autor und auch in paris das
tor von auch an amerikanischen
universitäten selbstverständlich
genommen und es gibt auch den
rückkopplungseffekt autoren aus dem
arabischen raum die in westeuropa in
nordamerika studiert haben wieder zurück
gehen und dort auch debatten
weiterführen die hier auch laufen oder
in anderer richtung weiterentwickeln
also es nicht so dass wir sozusagen im
westen eine debatte hätten und im
arabischen raum die durch die
globalisierung hat sich das natürlich
auch aber nimmt ja nicht als
philosophische debatte war sondern man
nimmt die debatte als clash of
civilizations als religiös der
unvereinbarkeit dass wir unseren das ist
also dass die signatur die die man
gegeben hat die bestimmte kreise im
westen gegeben haben und die als also
vor den arabern als hegemoniale von merz
bezeichnet würden und sonst nichts das
ist der versuch etwas zu systematisieren
und zuordnung bei denen dann immer die
perspektive des westens eigentlich im
vordergrund steht
wenn sie philosophie an den départements
in der islamischen welt seien es jetzt
arabische universitäten und persische
universitäten iran sehen dann haben sie
zu zwei dritteln auseinandersetzung mit
westlicher philosophie auf dem
curriculum und das nicht einfach im
sinne von nach lernen sondern mit
auseinandersetzungen also der frage was
sind das für argumente inwiefern sind
die wichtig und es gibt nehmen wir das
beispiel iran im moment ist das
heidecker gerade in ihrer der seit
jahren diskutiert wird auch vor was vor
allen dingen kann
übersetzt ins persische in großer anzahl
seiner werke und eine debatte über kant
im sinne von was sagt uns das anderes
wie können wir unsere eigenen
traditionen darauf beziehen
was hat das für unsere gesellschaftliche
realität möglicherweise für folgen mit
ganz unterschiedlichen positionen pro
und contra und so weiter also das heißt
es gibt noch mal versucht die die eine
eigenständige philosophie die sich nicht
als markt soziologie er steht in der
islamischen welt mir auf jeden fall
es gibt sie bei uns und es gibt einen
gemeinsamen nenner das sind gemeinsame
historische wurzeln die sich die sich
finden und könnte man dann sagen dass
wenn wir eine religiöse debatte führen
dass man diese religiöse debatte in die
philosophie ein bisschen weiterhin
übertragen könnte und dann dass man da
eine chance hätte ein besseres
verständnis jetzt auf jeden fall das
scheint mir ganz wichtig zu sein dass
man auch versucht religiöse debatten auf
rationalistische weise zu führen das
heißt und dass das in weiteren zu
verharren in der wurzel angelegt und
genau also den anderen zu fragen warum
glaubst du das oder wie kannst du eine
bestimmte position begründen und wie
gehst du mit dem und dem einwand um was
ist in unserer kultur genauso gibt wie
der islamischen und ich denke das wäre
ein wichtiger schritt dass man das ganze
zu sagen also politisch ideologischen
sphäre etwas rausholt und im gemeinsamen
gericht geklärt wird ob sie waren doch
mitverfasser des nationalfonds studie
zur ausbildung von imamen in der schweiz
also wer ist das ein thema dass man sagt
man kann eben genau über solche
philosophische fragestellungen
eine hat von verständnis brücken bauen
zwischen den religionen auf jeden fall
das thema dort war erst einmal bildung
ja klar bildung in einem breiten sind
was philosophie und theologische
tradition einschließt und die theologie
nicht reduziert auf aktuelle ansätze
sondern auch die ganze geschichte und
die ganze vielfalt mit denken kann
philosophie spielt insofern eine große
rolle als sie vermitteln kann sie ist ja
das was die verschiedenen positionen
befragt hinterfragt und auf eine andere
art und weise in argumente umwandelt das
kann man sehr gut aber auch da würde ich
jetzt hinzufügen region ist nicht das
einzige feld auf dem man das machen auch
heute auch in der arabischen welt und
der islamischen welt nicht das einzige
feld
es ist aber ein feld das extrem
produktiv sein kann vielleicht ein
beispiel lieder und mobilität das denken
wenn wir bestimmte argumente
gottesbeweis beispielsweise und deren
geschichte verfolgen dann geht das durch
die kulturen ansehen hat einen berühmten
gottesbeweis im mittelalter kant
kritisierten heutiger iranische autoren
kritisieren kann und das ist mobilität
entdecken da geht es eigentlich nicht
darum wer ist wo wer ist in welcher
kultur
da geht so argumente und um die frage ob
man gott beweisen kann
jetzt könnten wir sagen der iran hat ein
interesse daran ihn zu beweisen aber er
macht das nicht im sinne von ich glaube
sondern ich verstehe und er beleuchtet
das argument von kant höchst kritisch
und kommt dabei zu einwänden die sehr
gut nachvollziehbar sind
das ist mobilität das denken mobilität
des denkens wir haben lange darüber
gesprochen eine stunde lang die debatte
geht weiter ich wünsche ihnen viel kraft
und und auch wirklich erfolg bei diesen
vermittlungsarbeit zwischen dem osten
und dem westen
herzlichen dank intel wollten sie schon
lange wieder einmal ungehorsam seien
dann sollten sie nächste woche das
sternstunde gespräch mit dem
psychoanalytiker an ob du nicht
verpassen der uns wieder den gehorsam
wege zum freien denkens weißt ich freue
mich auf dieses amt
[Musik]